Now let's move on to another area in the study of social psychology and social
behavior. And that is the unfortunate bias of prejudice and resulting
discrimination. Prejudice is a biased attitude toward a group of people or an
individual member of a group based on unfair generalizations about what members
of that group are like. Such prejudicial thinking is often the result of
stereotypes. Instead of resulting from a careful observation of people's
behavior. If we have a prejudice that is based on race or ethnicity we call
that racism. Or if we have a prejudice based on the sexes. We call that sexism.
There is a lot of very interesting research, especially in the area of
industrial organizational psychology, that looks at both prejudice and
discrimination. So, remember that prejudice is a biased attitude. But when that
attitude changes to behavior. We see that discrimination can occur.
Discrimination is a preferential treatment of certain people usually driven by
prejudicial attitudes. Psychologists have suggested that prejudice operates
both inside and outside of our awareness. That is, we may be aware of our
prejudice. But we may also hold a prejudicial view without being aware of it.
Now, how do we know this? And how can we measure it? Two researchers, Banaji
and Greenwald, suspected that there was a disconnect between people's conscious
and unconscious views of prejudice. And they developed a very interesting way
to measure this. Go to the link below in the Instructor's notes section, and
take the test for racism.